[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
iaorana donc je vais vous parler de la
riche biodiversité du fenway ainsi que
malheureusement des menaces qui pèsent
sur elle
et donc là la fleur de polynésie
française comprend à peu près mille
plantes indigènes et endémiques
sur ce nombre là on en a 6 ans sont
uniques à la polynésie française sur ses
six ans vous en reconnaissez
quelques-unes sur les photos ici que me
tirer pétards y mais sachez que le tiare
apetahi c'est une seule il y en a 5 199
autres sur ce nombre là 300 sont
menacées de disparition et certaines
sont déjà éteintes au niveau des oiseaux
on a à peu près 100 espèces d'oiseaux
dont une soixantaine sont endémiques
propre à la poésie française reconnaît
ici ici martin chasseur le petit lob
carproof âge des marquises un puffin et
notre monarque
sur ce nombre là sur les 100 espèces
d'oiseaux connu pour la police française
une trentaine sont déjà éteintes ont
disparu la superficie du globe et sur
les quelques dizaines qui reste une
quarantaine sont menacées d'extinction
pour quelles raisons est ce que c'est
ces animaux et ces plantes sont la
disparition c'est en grande partie à
cause des espèces exotiques
envahissantes
c'est à dire à la fois des plantes ou
des animaux qui ont été introduits par
l'homme depuis aujourd'hui plus d'une
plus de mille ans en polynésie
pourquoi est ce que nos îles
polynésiennes sont si sensibles à
l'introduction de ces plantes des
animaux
c'est en grande partie car elles sont
très isolés des continents très peu de
plantes ont pu venir ont pu coloniser et
elles sont souvent sans défense devant
les espèces introduites ces espèces
introduites par exemple sont des
mammifères qui était complètement absent
de la faune locale les plantes locales
également non pas de généralement des
pin n'ont pas de feu et toxiques
donc c'est très sensible à une chèvre un
boeuf un cheval la situation est
identique dans les autres îles du
pacifique voire même l'atlantique c'est
pas unique à la police française
donc quoi faire pour essayer de
contrecarrer ce développement des
plantes et les animaux envahissant qui
pose problème à notre flore donc je vais
vous présenter quelques exemples de ce
qui est fait en polynésie donc l'exemple
pris est celui du monarque de tahiti aux
mains ou en tahitien sur les
photographies vous avez 2
oizo 1 et le jeune le juvénile qui est
orange l'autre et adultes donc c'est un
oiseau qui est également très très
sympathique par son chant il change
complètement du chant du merle habituels
ou de bulbul habituel il est territorial
c'est à dire que chaque année il revient
sur les mêmes territoires pour se
reproduire et généralement il est fidèle
relativement fidèle annoncent à son
importance pour la suite enfin c'est un
oiseau qui insectivores donc ce n'est
pas un oiseau qui va disséminer les
graines de plantes rares
ils mangent les insectes sur l'île de
tahiti il y a plus de 200 ans
ils étaient présents depuis niveau de la
mer jusqu'à 1000 mètres d'altitude
aujourd'hui n'est plus présent que dans
trois vallées avaler une marois peau à
punaauia
il va aller d'europa et de pape est loué
à pareil donc quelles sont les raisons
de cet arrêt faction le les principales
raisons tout d'abord les animaux qui
pose problème à cet oiseau là ce sont
essentiellement donc le rat noir qui a
été introduit il ya 200 ans par les
navigateurs européens qui consomment à
la fois les poussins la fois les eaux de
l'oiseau de la même façon le busard de
gould introduit pour manger les rats le
maire des moluques on mangeait les
guêpes sont aussi des prédateurs des
poux 5 des e on a des compétiteurs comme
le bulbul en bas à droite qui va entrer
en compétition avec l'oiseau avec le
monarque sur six territoires ainsi que
la petite fourmi de feu qui est assez
célèbre ces dernières années pour son
invasion dans les en polynésie française
et à tahiti en particulier qui
consomment les insectes dont se nourrit
loiseau enfin les chèvres qui menacent
l'habitat de l'oiseau en consommant les
plantes hôtes des insectes ou les
plantes sur lesquelles e
ils peuvent se reproduire à côté de ces
animaux on a aussi quelques plantes
envahissantes
je vous en présente deux uniquement le
tulipier du gabon qui aujourd'hui
représente à peu près 90% des arbres ils
sont présents dans les vallées à
monarque qui sont des arbres assez
fragile l'oiseau ne niche pas dedans
puisque quand il ya un peu de vent les
branches casse les branches bouge qui
massacrent un petit peu le sous-bois
aussi à cause de tous les chablis tous
les jolis la deuxième espèce le miconia
le plus célèbre lui fait des sous bois
complètement hermétique à la lumière en
pêche la régénération de toutes les
espèces que ce soit des mousses ou des
fougères dans le sous-bois et donc
quelque part détruit petit à petit tout
l'habitat de l'oiseau qu'est ce qui a
été fait depuis une vingtaine d'années
par l'association manu qui essaient de
sauvegarder cet oiseau là donc il ya des
grandes campagnes de dératisation toute
l'année depuis une vingtaine d'années
maintenant des campagnes aussi de
contrôler des oiseaux introduit donc de
piégeage de merle de bulbul de busards
et aussi des contrôles des campagnes de
contrôle de des espèces envahissantes
avec notamment des campagnes de
bénévoles pour faire ceci
donc si certaines de ses actions sont
réalisées directement par les salariés
de l'association
un grand nombre d'actions qui nécessite
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de moyens
sont faits par des bénévoles
donc je vais vous parler plus
particulièrement maintenant des
campagnes fait pour lutter contre le
miconia dans les vallées en monarque
donc depuis quatre ans et demi que ça a
été mais en place on a pu tenir à peu
près 60 campagne une par mois en moyenne
ce sont huit cent trente personnes qui
ont pu nous accompagner à raison d'une
quinzaine par sortie donc ces campagnes
ont été un succès elle consiste à
arracher au maximum les pieds de miconia
est ce qu'on ne peut pas arracher car
ils sont trop gros on va l'essayer à la
base et comme toute plante envahissante
qui se respecte le miconia va repousser
si on le fait que le seae donc on traite
avec un produit herbicides uniquement
les souches on a coupé
voici quelques photographies avant notre
passage
après notre passage la même journée les
miconia sont coupées sont laissés sur
place au bout de quelques mois ils vont
complètement pourrir et on aura
l'impression qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
miconia dans la zone nous savions dès le
départ de ces types d'actions il fallait
qu'on puisse tenir sur la durée
il fallait qu'on puisse mobiliser les
bénévoles pendant plusieurs années pour
avoir pour espérer avoir un impact
durable
on nous a souvent dit c'est pas la peine
de vous attaquer aux miconia il y en a
partout à tahiti ça pousse trop vite on
peut rien faire faudra trouver une autre
solution donc néanmoins on a décidé de
toujours poursuivre ce projet là et donc
pour mobiliser encore et encore il a
fallu qu'on
ned et technique un peu particulière
puisque même si on est peut-être bon en
plantes
je suis botaniste au départ d'autres
sont bons pour gérer les oiseaux on a
été très mauvais en communication au
départ votre première campagne a
simplement réunit trois personnes - même
une salariée d'associations et un membre
du bureau donc sûrement quelques
personnes se sont dit ah ouais ça fait
pitié
il va falloir qu'on vienne les aider les
gens qui avaient envie de participer à
ces campagnes de faire quelque chose
pour l'heure fait noir pour l'heure
l'oiseau pour leurs plantes dont il
était un peu plus doux avec nous et ils
ont réussi à mettre en place des fédés à
travers les réseaux sociaux des moyens
de communiquer et de recruter des
bénévoles depuis quatre ans et demi dans
quelles sont les motivations tous ces
gens là vous voyez en plus certaines
vallées sont difficilement accessibles
il faut qu'on remonte des cascades avec
des cordes ou des échelles métalliques
et redescend en rappel qu'est ce qui
motive tout ce monde là on va commencer
par mes motivations du moins une partie
certaine je vais sûrement les cacher
donc j'ai participé bon à 59 des 60
sorties
donc je suis assez fidèle à ses sorties
qu'est-ce qui est l'art et la motivation
officielle normalement c'est sauver
sauver le petit oiseau au départ
shibutani ce donc j'aime bien sauver les
petites plantes c'était mon voeu quand
j'étais enfant
donc c'est que par une grosse
satisfaction mais en fait la vérité est
probablement un peu ailleurs
tout d'abord il faut que ça me puisse et
ce type de sortie me plaisent si je fais
ce ces travaux là je le fais d'abord
pour moi ça me fasse plaisir tant mieux
si ça fait plaisir à d'autres personnes
ou si ça fait plaisir à l'environnement
ça me permet quelque part de me protéger
aussi si un jour on se retrouve à
nouveau à trois ou quatre pour la sortie
pourquoi est ce que les gens ne sont pas
venus
est-ce que je dois leur en vouloir ou
non donc mon principe c'est pas d'en
vouloir aux gens on travaille je
travaille d'abord pour moi pour me faire
plaisir
on ne fait pour fait une sorte de
démonstration ou preuve par l'exemple
on ne donne pas des leçons si les gens
veulent venir il le peut sans problème
un autre aspect c'est là là l'aspect
affectif affectif de la le plaisir
instinctif en fait de couper tous les
miconia de nettoyer les versants de ne
plus laisser un seul tronc d'arbre
orange sur le versant je suis pas doué
pour passer le balai chez moi mais pour
passer le balai dans la vallée et
nettoyé tous les nids cognera n'en
laisser aucun je suis assez doué je
pense que beaucoup des bénévoles aime
bien cet aspect un petit peu nom
scientifique est complètement instinctif
un deuxième aspect c'est l'aspect
sportif donc faire des sorties une fois
par mois un minima ça permet de sortir
un petit peu tichy de chez soi devant
son ordinateur et les bénévoles souvent
me dise puisqu'il y à une heure et demie
de marche à l'aller une heure et demie
de marche retour on coupe pendant trois
heures la journée sur des pentes très
fortes ont souvent ils me disent c'est
pas la peine est allé à la salle ça fait
travailler tous et les jambes et les
bras donc l'aspect sportif est
indubitable un autre aspect aussi
sensibiliser au maximum la population
en tout cas les bénévoles leur donner
des clés d'interprétation de ce qui se
passe dans la vallée car la plupart des
gens ont l'habitude d'être sur le
littoral en bord de mer voilà montagne
tout weert bel de loin mais se rendent
pas compte tout à fait ce qui se passe
de sous donc l'idée de donner des
éléments pour expliquer la dynamique de
la végétation la dynamique de l'avifaune
ça leur permet aussi de prendre prendre
de prendre conscience de ce qui se passe
de temps en temps cette prise de
conscience est douloureuse
j'ai un ami aux marquises il m'avait dit
jean-françois avant que tu m'explique
tout ça je pensais que la montagne a été
belle c'était bucolique j'étais heureux
d'aller voyage et marcher en montagne
depuis que je lui ai expliqué ils voient
bien ce qui se passe et il est
complètement dépressif ou presque il
voit la chose beaucoup plus tristement
puisque on a beaucoup de problèmes avec
ces espèces envahissantes
les bénévoles quant à eux quelles sont
leurs motivations certains sont devenus
amoureux du monarque amoureux de
l'oiseau de son champ de ses couleurs
ils ont ils sont aussi très tu sais un
petit peu anthropomorphique puisque le
monarque plus les oiseaux sont bagués je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'ils
étaient relativement fidèle donc d'une
année sur l'autre on est censé retrouver
les mêmes couples mais en fait ça se
passe pas comme ça tout le temps
le petit jeune est allé avec la la
cougar ou la petite jeune s'est fait
attraper par le le vieux à côté donc
c'est c'est assez plaisant voici en
guise en tout cas pour les gens de 2,6
tout cela une autre espèce et de ré
ouvrir les sentiers donc les certains
bénévoles viennent de la randonnée dont
qu'ils apprécient de ré ouvrir les
sentiers en coupant les miconia en
réouvrant les rivières la lumière vient
au niveau du sol
c'est à nouveau bucolique à nouveau
plaisant pour ce pour se baigner
également certains bénévoles prennent
plaisir à encadrer eux mêmes les sorties
donc expliquer aux autres personnes
commencent que ça se passe qu'est ce qui
se passe au niveau du d'une icône ya des
oiseaux
donc c'est assez un plaisir de voir ceci
d'ailleurs c'est tellement c'est aussi
le plaisir d'être en groupe on fait
quelque chose de fou qui a été considéré
comme fou puisque s'attaquer aux miconia
était à la main on n'utilise pas de
tronçonneuses on a connu une petite scie
s'attaque le miconia était considéré
assez assez fou donc on s'attaque en
groupe à quelque chose de fou donc soit
on est fou soit on n'est pas si fou que
ça d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on essaie
d'élargir nos campagnes ou tulipier du
gabon est également faire des
plantations et pour cela en impliquant
des enfants notamment
donc pour toutes ces raisons certains
des bénévoles
en tout cas la famille de certains des
bénévoles leurs amis se voit répondre
quand il les invite les bénévoles le
week-end à faire une activité
bah je ne peux pas venir car demain j'ai
miconia à côté de ces de ses motivations
on a quelques impacts motivation
prévisible on a quelques impacts
collatéraux l'impact collatéral ne doit
pas être vu comme négatifs comme le
dommage collatéral je suis assez fier de
ses impacts collatéraux fier ou quelque
part je suis chanceux d'avoir été là
pour pour le vivre et pour les
déclencher
c
c'est beaucoup d'amitié beaucoup de gens
sont venus à ces sorties là sans se
connaître les uns les autres
aujourd'hui sont devenus les meilleurs
amis du monde il se ils font des
activités ensemble bien en dehors du
miconia moi même j'ai eu plusieurs
plusieurs amis qui viennent du mythe
cognin alors qu'au départ j allais pas
forcément pour rencontrer les gens
peut-être pour me défouler et c'est un
autre
un autre aspect on a pu bénéficier aussi
la volonté de retour aux sources de la
plupart de pas mal de personnes qui sont
devenues citadins et qui avait envie de
retourner aux mines dans le milieu
naturel et on l'a on leur a permis de
retrouver un petit peu leurs racines et
de faire des actions en faveur la
conservation de la biodiversité
certains des bénévoles qui souhaitaient
venir notamment des gens de montréal ont
monté leur association donc
l'implication de ces de ses bénévoles
dans d'autres associations
donc ceux de mourey a monté une
association qui s'appelle moorea
biodiversité qui active ou six chansons
elle avait dû me cogner à moorea ils ont
pu travailler aussi la même façon à
combattre ne m'y connais en tout cas
surpris ne vous certains membres du
bureau de l'association manou sont aussi
venus dans le bureau à travers les
actions contre le miconia donc ça c'est
un plaisir
d'ailleurs certains membres du bureau
ont trouvé un petit peu plus que de
l'amitié dans ses campagnes là enfin
pour conclure on voit puis une petite
action sur une espèce envahissante
majeur a pu a pu avoir des impacts
positifs sur le mail naturel puisque
dans les vallées aujourd'hui à un
monarque on a plus beaucoup de forêts
demi cognin c'est un petit peu triste
pour nous parce qu'on adorait faire ça
va falloir qu'on fasse évoluer mais on a
eu un réel impact aussi sur un réac
impact humain c'est une alliance denture
humaine on s'aperçut que c'était la
volonté de sauver le monde qui sauvait
le monde sauvé loiseau il nous a initié
l'action
mais ce qui nous fait tenir depuis
quatre ans et demi ce sont toutes les
petites choses que je vous ai raconté
sur les motivations et les impacts
donc j'espère que ça vous aura donné des
idées pour faire quelques actions on a
besoin de vous et de vos enfants puisque
on a commencé à planter des arbres donc
il faudra les entretenir pendant dix ou
vingt ans donc faire des actions et puis
n'oubliez pas demain j'ai miconia merci
[Applaudissements]